Let's go to Craig from Montreal, Quebec, Canada.
Creg from Montreal. You were on the air. Hi,
David. How are you? Good. How are you?
I'm great. It's my first time calling into
any show, so thanks for having me. Well, listen,
I don't know if you know this.
Montreal, one of my favorite places in the
northeast of the of the continent, I guess
I would say that's a specific part of the
continent.
But I love that, you know, we're over in New
York City, I guess, and the.
Well, I didn't say over. I said one of my
favorite O Gemini stuff getting cocky here.
But it's actually good that you got another
Canadian on the line because I was just listening
to the charity comments. Yeah, he's not obviously
the numbers were way off that he gave, but
the scandal does exist. So the his his mother,
Margaret Trudeau, got paid at around two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars.
OK, conference that I believe that's salaries.
That certainly sounds like the type of cronyism
we've come to be very accustomed to in the
exactly the the program itself.
They were given around nine hundred million
dollars. And some of these payments, like
his Trudeau's wife, got like fifteen hundred
dollars for speech. Yeah. It's like, you know,
and I, I, I hate this kind of corruption and
it's part of why I'm calling you. I guess
I'm a little bit vague. I don't have a direct
question, but something that you talk about
frequently on the show is how the world is
sadly looking at the US right now. And it's
it's something that's we're looking at the
US sad, but we're also feeling that influence
spreading into our countries as well. And,
you know, just in Montreal in the last couple
of months, we had a Trump rally, not a Trump
rally, sorry, a Trump protest, kind of where
it was an anti mask mixed with Trump. Twenty
twenty. Oh, dear God. And this is in Montreal,
Quebec. You know, that's it. Were so just
to see how far this spreads and how far this
mentality of misinformation goes deeper than
just Donald Trump.
And I have a really hard time putting my finger
on this phenomenon and knowing how we can
defeat it, because once facts are out of the
game or one's reasonable conversation is out,
you know, and I feel like what do the last
two sentences I just said are said on the
right to like they say, we're not reasonable.
We don't want to talk, of course. Oh, yeah.
But I mean, Trump Trump protests in Montreal
are quite, quite a new that. That's a new
level. That's pretty wild. Now, let me ask
you this. Go ahead. Within Canada, how do
the what is the the perception of like, OK,
in Europe it tends to be you look to the country,
to the west, and you think you're better than
them. So the Spanish think they're better
than the Portuguese and the French think they're
better than the Spanish, you know, so on and
so forth in Canada. Do the I think they are
better than the non French Canadians or how
does that hierarchy work?
So that's interesting. You know, and you're
talking I'm actually a French Canadian. I've
just been lucky to speak. I went to Ontario
for school for a little while. So I speak
really good English, but so I'm actually French
Canadian. So coming from this background,
there is, I'd say, the whole separatism thing.
And French English like culture war has definitely
died down over the last few decades.
But don't forget our last referendum to separate
from Canada was in the nineties. Right. So
it's not these these legacies aren't far off.
And there's still people like that. I grew
up with are are for the party Québecois,
which is separatist. And there's still. There's
actually left wing parties in Quebec, like
Quebec Solidaire, for example, that have extremely
awesome left wing ideas and really want like
our to culturalism environmentalism and stuff,
but also have separatist ideas. So it's it's
a funny mix of stuff you're going on in Quebec.
But my main issue, like you were saying, though.
Yes, Quebec, like there is something called
the Western alienation in Canada, where the
western provinces, British Columbia, Saskatchewan,
Alberta, feel alienated by the eastern provinces
because that's where the economy is the biggest
and so where the heads of power are.
So it sounds like you're saying you do think
you're better than Matt from Windsor?
Oh, absolutely. I don't. I would love to take
that back. No, it's but I I guess what I'm
saying is I find the left. It's hard to be
on the left sometimes.
So I want to be on the left with the government
like Trudeau. But they lose credibility with
the corruption. And he was in blackface. You
know, it's just it's hard to take them seriously.
And you also have new parties coming in, like
the Peoples Party of Canada, which is kind
of a Trump kind of a Tea Party ish vibe. So
worried about all these powers coming up in
countries that are known to be really liberal
that, yes, that is that is a global a global
trend.
Well, listen, I appreciate the call. Have
you ever been to the Great Cafe, Tommy, in
old Montreal?
Absolutely. That's a great response. If you
come back, I'd recommend going to Cafe Myriad.
OK, very good. And the coffee will be appropriate
there. I won't have.
Oh, absolutely. I've even worked there, so
I vouch for them. Very good. All right, Greg
from Montreal, thank you. Thank you so much.
All right. Very good. We're going to take
a quick break. If you are holding on to talk
to me, please don't hang up because we're
going right back to the phones. The David
Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.